[Musique]
non sans blague
il t'a dit ça à toi à moi et qu'est ce
qui s'est passé moi je le regardais dans
les yeux j'ai dit je pense savoir de
quel coffre à jouets tu sors avec mes
romans makarov qui couine sinon tu
t'arranges la figure comme il faut je ne
crois pas tu as grand ouest watts et pas
un petit nounours mon pote tu as fou fou
ça ouais t'as vu la nouvelle bande
annonce de quoi t'es pas au courant de
quoi tu parles on la porte devine quoi
ils vont bientôt sortir à nouveau toy
story non je croyais que c'était fini
depuis longtemps ils ont déjà fait trois
on a fait 3 mais là ce numéro quatre
adolescents history ça déchire tôt en
fatigue passif et nous buzz les pères de
son buzz l'éclair ranger des spas et
woody lui dit tu n'es qu'elle ferait
timide vachement mieux rudi fait le
quand ils s'envolent vas-y vas-y vas-y
vers la freiner à temps
c'est pas ça des jeux ouais c'est pas ça
moi je suis sûr que j'ai quand même
écoute leur amnésie et je ne fais pas
c'est complètement mais c'est ce qu'ils
disent et bill maher berlin samedi
elle a chocolat non vers la mairie
les gars c'est pas du tout ça c'est mr
l'infini et au delà
quarto qu'on peut pas aller vers
l'infini souffre au possible
iacono faut que tu prennes des cours de
sciences ponga
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]